for Adam Ishmael who's saying it was a
stroke of good fortune to find a job and
a teacher at this cafe in Lower Saxony
one that shared his name here at Adams
cafe the Sudanese man was learning to be
a pastry chef but his future is
uncertain
his employer died recently and now Adam
faces the threat of deportation but he's
determined to finish his training it's
very interesting I love my work and I do
it with pleasure who now runs her late
husband's bakery wants to keep Adam on
she has a lot of support among her
customers personally I can only see this
cafe surviving with Adam here he bakes
just like my husband did Adam makes the
plum cake that's been served here for
the last 50 years
he's mastered it in the last half-year I
don't believe it's so easy just to
replace people's income the Adams have
long considered Adam Ishmael Hussein to
be part of the family
axl Adam seen here in footage from a
year ago
had hoped his apprentice might take over
the business one day the community is
supportive of the 30 year old Sudanese
man the Chamber of Commerce has been
campaigning for him and a retired master
confectioner who has experience working
with migrants wants to help Adam finish
his training I'm concerned about his
situation and that motivates me to help
to do what I can to ensure that Adam
finishes the training is the gun I feel
that in the short time we've spent
together we've gotten to know each other
and we've established a good rapport
eunbok and on the harm is what I run
here I would like to stay here and
finish my training and then I would like
to carry on working that can only happen
if the authorities agree next Monday a
special cases Commission is set to
review his application to stay in
Germany